yay
[Music]
100k
nice big celebration we have just
reached 100 000 subscribers now truth be
told as of recording of this videos uh
we actually don't have a hundred
thousand subscribers yet there's like
missing so all i have to do is not get
cancelled in the next two days or so and
this is harder than it seems but i've
managed so far i think i can make it so
thank you everyone who's been here for
any amount of time 100 000 of you have
decided to click on the subscribe button
and i'm eternally grateful to every
single one i would have never ever ever
thought that a dude on youtube talking
for 45 minutes about research papers and
stuff would get any attention at all pun
intended but hey uh it's come to this so
thank you all so much this has been
absolutely great i have no intention of
stopping now this video right here is
supposed to be a little bit of an
announcement video and also i thought
we'd look a little bit into the channel
statistics because i know some of you
are interested so what are the
announcements as i said i have no
intention of stopping reaching 100k
doesn't make a big difference in terms
of content in fact i have lots of ideas
for nice content and probably more ideas
than time to implement them but there's
some cool stuff coming up also i will be
hosting and ask me anything on probably
sunday and it's gonna happen here on
youtube so you'll see that pop up if
you're around at that time next thing
merch so i thought be funny to have a
little bit of channel merch and i don't
have it ready yet but we'll chat on
discord a little bit about what is going
to be offered because i do want your
inputs into these kinds of things so
let's get some funny merch and i think
that'll be cool speaking of discord
special thanks to everyone who is there
who participates to everyone who has
ever asked and to everyone who has ever
answered a question in the help channel
to everyone who has participated or even
just listened to the paper discussions
we host there a special thanks to the
regulars and to the moderators who keep
everything going this would absolutely
not be possible if it were just myself
so huge thanks to everyone there this
community is just amazing and we would
not be at 100k right now if it weren't
for the support that i'm getting from
there if you're not yet a discord member
and you do want to be more involved link
is right there in the description
everyone's welcome as i said next to the
usual discord chit chat we have regular
paper discussions and also there are
some community projects currently there
is one called homebrew nlp where the
goal is to build a framework that can
run really large language models on a
single machine if you're interested in
that absolutely join and participate in
creation of that very cool okay that
being said let's dive a little bit into
the channel statistics
now i i think due to the rules of
adsense i'm not allowed to show you the
exact numbers of revenue that come from
ads not entirely sure that's a rule
actually but i have heard it from
somewhere and i'd rather not get into
trouble safe to say it's not nearly a
number where you could live off of this
or anything like this it did support for
example the new camera that i've gotten
so you can enjoy me in excellent quality
also thanks of course to the patreons
and subscribe star supporters and also
the people who've sent me a bit of
crypto this has also enabled me to get a
new ipad instead of my old surface
tablet which makes the creation of the
paper reviews just a lot easier so
thanks a lot for that so here i've
pulled up statistics since january 2020.
i have made numerous videos before that
but not nearly at the scale or frequency
that i'm making them now so the real
video making started in the early days
of 2020 when the first wave of the
current global phenomenon hit and i
suddenly found myself with a bit of more
time on my hands and at that time i was
watching a lot of videos by people like
pewdiepie and casey neistat and i deep
respect for these people that upload
every single day and i asked myself
how long could i keep this up and it
turned out i could keep it up for about
three to four months so as you can see
youtube is mostly a grind with a few
intermittent spikes i believe the first
spike here is gpt-3 and the second spike
is alpha fold you can also see the times
i took a couple of breaks namely here in
late summer of 2020 and in early summer
of this year it's pretty cool how you
can see all of this in the stats also
we've recently passed 4 million views
which is crazy interestingly here you
can see while a lot of people appear to
have watched the gpt-3 video not a lot
of people have watched it to the end see
the difference
spike
no spike
no spike maybe that was a different
video
top videos of course the all-time
favorite attention is all you need see
i've uploaded this in 2017 and it's
drawn people ever since which means i
must have done something right now
people have told me to get a thumbnail
for this going or anything like this but
i'm not i'm not gonna change a single
thing about this video it's doing well
people are watching it for a long time
not gonna change a thing here you see
other popular videos are alpha fold and
gpt3 now also surprising is transcoder
which a lot of people watch but then
they watch kind of none of it so this
might have been the big spike now i'm
not sure if the thumbnail here is
misleading and people expected coding
content rather than an analysis of a
research paper or it's because the first
part of this word is sort of politically
overloaded and maybe people clicked on
that or the algorithm recommended that
to people i'm not sure but it is what it
is
interestingly click-through rate has
been going steadily down i'm not sure if
that is to be expected as you grow i
guess
i'm not sure but maybe i should do a
little bit more clickbait to get people
to click more when people search for
this channel the most thing they search
is my name which is quite flattering and
then it is the titles of the videos
they're interested in such as attention
is all you need gpt3 alpha fold or
vision transformer which was a cool
video if you remember i reviewed that
before it was clear who the authors were
and i sort of de-anonymized the paper uh
live and
yeah i thought that was funny
so who are you you are probably on
youtube mostly around 6 p.m in central
europe you're probably also subscribed
to two minute papers lex friedman tesla
the emma street talk and sabine
hossenfelder among other channels now a
specific shout out to ml street talk if
you're not subscribed to that i can
highly recommend it i'm part of it not
always but a lot of times and we have
super duper interesting discussions with
people that i would have never
guessed i could ever reach and talk to
and ask them questions so i think we
have really cool guests and the
conversations are often quite technical
so i think you will enjoy that
in terms of watch time only about half
the people are subscribed which is
surprising that means 200k subscribers
isn't far away
and 19 out of 20 of you are probably
male and a lot of you are between 25 and
34 years old now i'm never sure if that
is just the statistics of the people
where youtube knows what they are
because they've specified it somewhere
or is that what they guess about people
in which case i guess that would be
seriously distorted because the guessing
would probably be based on something
like your interests which might be that
if you're into a lot of technical
subjects you're more likely to be male
but then you count that to the statistic
here and probably that statistic is then
used again for training the algorithms
i'm not sure so i'm not gonna interpret
too much into this thing right here also
you're quite likely to be from the
united states or india but really the
geographies are distributed
quite all over the world okay i've
actually figured it out yes the giant
spike was in fact the transcoder video
and here you can see that the traffic
source was mostly external so
in fact the gpt-3 video was a much
smaller spike not much earlier than the
transcoder spike so this was it for the
channel statistics for the celebration
of 100k thank you so much to everyone
who is here to everyone who's helped and
who's participated i hope you still
enjoy the content i still read all the
comments if you have any feedback any
wishes or anything like this let me know
i'm looking forward to what's to come
and have a great day bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you